this is green energy and you can create
energy instantly my name is bjorn
westerholt
I'm the CEO of YFC holdings in Sweden
this product is a fuel cell shorter it's
two different parts the fuel cell itself
with all the electronics and everything
that you need and the fuel part that
includes everything that creates the
hydrogen itself we thought that the
first products were more a a our storage
product
it included a battery as well the court
it was basically a hybrid what we do
here is that we have the water tray
inside here and here we filling water
spreads all around the fuel cell itself
now we're going to demonstrate for you
how it works we reduce it works like
this
these will be something like 1.5 to 1.8
dollars that's the goal for us when we
launched the product distort the
shipping it in q4 2015 everything in the
court is is recycled material from the
stores and there is no harm for things
in the court of the video of you stays
at all so it's actually you can throw it
in the bin